an insider account of American policing
from former Seattle police chief norm
Stamper this talk from the University
Bookstore in Tacoma Washington is about
an hour I don't think that mr. Stamper
needs any introduction for me it looks
like you're all good friends with him
we're just so thrilled to have him
attended a Bruce Springsteen concert
about a week ago I'm almost excited
about distance combat oh dredging you're
credible yeah honor to have somebody the
cute former police chief for for 35
years who did so much to change the way
think things are handling the police
department is special when it comes to
domestic violence and I think of all the
things you could have done especially
when you run for mayor so um the book is
fabulous and rule says that in a
shocking and hysterical and illuminating
so I'm not going to waste your time
anymore just mr. Stanford take it away
thank you so much for thanks just a real
honor
thank you very much Laura Jack right in
person nice to meet you this evening
I've met two people with whom I've been
in correspondence for eight a long long
time and actually have now been able to
match a face to the to the unending
series of emails and it's very nice to
see all of you here tonight what I
thought I would do this evening is talk
to you a little bit about why I wrote
this book and in the process share some
information about its structure then do
a little bit of reading and and then
take questions or listen to concerns
that you may have based on anything
that's either in the book or that I may
say tonight that triggers any kind of a
reaction and I begin by saying that I
think policing American policing is
strategically located in our society to
accomplish two major purposes that means
so much to every single one of us as
Americans the first is its
crime-fighting mission
prevention of crime the enforcement of
criminal statutes and helping to create
and sustain safe and healthy
neighborhoods the basic core mission of
policing I also see it however as the as
a basic core mission that police
officers uphold constitutional rights
and due process guarantees of each and
every one of us
guaranteeing civil liberties and
actually contributing to social justice
by working lawfully to improve
neighborhoods and communities and to
make them safe is seen by a lot of
people is either oxymoronic or just
plain moronic you can't possibly do one
and the other so it has to be an
either/or proposition and I think that
is a fundamental failing and logic
particularly given the structure of
government that we have in this country
so reason number one for writing the
book was to express concerns that I have
had throughout most of my career
certainly not my rookie year but most of
my career about the institution itself
the structure the paramilitary
bureaucratic organizational arrangement
and all of the problems that result from
that kind of institutional structure
there are laws as well that police are
called upon to enforce that helped to
contribute to a very antagonistic
sometimes almost always adversarial
relationship between police officers and
very large classes of people in our
society and I'll be talking about that
in just a few moments so reason number
one is all about reform reforming the
structure of policing reform in some of
the laws that police officers are called
upon to enforce on behalf of each of us
the second motivation for writing this
book was to give myself an opportunity
to explore why I became a cop in the
first place in 1966 and how breathtaking
the quick and easy it was for me to more
from a vaguely idealistic 21 year old
kid into a reckless abusive police
officer during my rookie year a rookie
year that I hasten to add I enjoyed very
much I enjoyed the power
I enjoyed abusing other citizens that
becomes very important it seems to me as
we as we do some soul-searching and
institutional analysis of policing so
that's kind of the introduction the book
is as it's been called by my publisher
is part to linic that's the political
piece in part memoir which is obviously
a bit of my own story so what I'd like
to do is just read some excerpts I'll be
skipping around quite a bit but I think
you'll see that there is something
resembling a theme to the reading this
evening and then once again want to
reserve as much time as possible for
conversation with you so if I can work
my way through these highly organized
notes I'm at a meeting on Capitol Hill
in Seattle I get beeped there's been a
shooting an address shows up on my pager
and I know right where it is it's across
the street from common ground a social
services agency that oversees the safe
transfer of children in joint custody
cases you know mom drops a kid off at 8
o'clock dad picks the child up at 8:15
dad returns the kid at 5:00 mom picks
the child up at 5:15 that why that way
mom and dad just don't have to see each
other presumably making it safe I glide
my vehicle under the outer perimeter
tape held high by two of my officers and
pull up to the inner perimeter a car is
parked facing south in the northbound
lane it's driver's door open its dome
light on lieutenant Harry Bailey says I
thought you'd want to roll on this one
boss he's right and he's wrong
behind the wheel of the car is the
sprawled body of a woman dressed in
business attire she's dead in back
buckled snugly into her car seat a
little girl about two white tights
patent leather shoes plaid skirt puffy
oversized nylon jacket dark curly hair
long eyelashes the face of an angel her
eyes are wide open her two little fists
clenched
she's also dead shot through the chest a
week later her father Carl Edwards shot
himself as a CHP moved in on him just
north of the Golden Gate Bridge what do
you see when you picture a safe America
I envision infants born into loving into
a loving nurturing world two women whose
reproductive rights are protected by law
children and teens who exhibit
consideration for themselves and for
others and who and and citizens who
question and challenge and disagree with
one another non-violently men who
refused to abuse women gun violence gone
from our homes in our streets our
schools and our workplaces law enforcers
from the beat cop to the Attorney
General
doing their jobs properly applying their
imagination playing by the rules
I see Americans black white straight gay
expressing themselves freely pursuing
happiness as they define it my picture
in America safe from consumer
environmental and political as well as
predatory crime and free from the
specter of an overzealous
overreaching moralistic government as I
think most people in this city know who
know anything about the book chapter one
is an open letter to a bad cop that bad
cop is David brain in this chapter I
talk about my own abuse of each of my
three ex-spouses then my violence never
led to bruises or cuts or broken bones
much less a 45 bullet to the head
makes my violence directed at someone I
purported to love no less acceptable and
throughout our society it seems to me if
we recognize that violence in the home
is a precursor to violence every well
everywhere then we will in fact muster
the courage the money the priorities we
need to in fact do everything in our
power to prevent domestic violence
research over the past three decades
supports the conventional wisdom witness
your parents fighting statistically
you're likely to grow into a batterer
yourself beaten as a child odds are
you'll beat your own kids if you're both
a witness to and a victim of family
abuse your chances of becoming a partner
beater and/or a child abuser unless you
have some remarkable coping skills or
some other adult to turn to for support
or just off the charts and god forbid
you should grow up in a household where
violence is the norm spousal assault
child assault and everyday vocabulary of
violence eat those peas or I'll kick
your ass wipe that smirk off your face
or I'll slap it off
and yes mega-doses of TV and video game
violence if you come from that kind of
home and so many American children do
the chances are slight that you'll not
settle differences with your fists or a
hammer or a gun either that says the
research or you'll turn out
pathologically passive in my letter to
David I I asked him about his attitudes
toward women and where he got them and I
think it's important that we consider
that I also think it's important that we
focus on the behavior no matter what may
have produced or contributed to it
the pushing the threats to kill her the
choking David four episodes in the year
before you murdered her
the angry display of your firearm I hate
to say it but that stuff's not all
uncommon among young male cops or older
male cops or men in general but you did
some certifiably weird things too you
sent her flowers with no card so you
could study her reaction you timed her
every trip from the house you checked
the odometer on her car
you accompanied her to the bathroom and
enter into her gynecological exams you
weighed her daily you handled all the
money giving her a miserly allowance
than accounting for it like a cross
between Scrooge and Attila the Hun I
wonder David if you also listened in on
her phone conversations read her mail
followed her interrogated her when she
got home demanding to know what she did
who she was with expected or demanded
sex when she didn't want it this list
has 51 items I'll spare you the time
you're probably familiar with it if not
please read
pay more very very important to know the
signs and symptoms of a batterer
the whole world knows the answer to the
last two questions David did you fight
in front of the kids
did you use violence against her on
October excuse me on April the 26th 2003
we do know that David brain shot and
killed his wife then himself in front of
his eight-year-old daughter and his
five-year-old son I've been married and
divorced three times I recall what it
was like to be provoked the rage that
welled up inside when I felt jealous or
possessive or disrespected or insecure I
did things I regret and since I'm not
shy about judging you I'll tell you what
they are
I screamed profanities at my wife in
front of the kids two stepchildren from
the second marriage my own from the
first I turned cold gave her the silent
treatment once slam my fist into the
wall interrogated her when she returned
home surely she had been sleeping or at
least flirting with someone else I
glared at her drove at breakneck speeds
with her in the car
lifted her and moved her when she
refused to get out of a doorway so I
could leave which is to say escape that
was my favorite tactic get to the car
roll down all the windows motor like a
madman into the mountains or out onto
the desert floor until I had calmed down
and regained something of my senses
which wife doesn't matter I behaved the
same way with each habitually the worst
thing I ever did from where I sit was to
stand above the woman I loved and rain
down madness upon her I was carrying my
seventh or eighth of my nine badges by
then each new professional milestone
symbolizing it might
illusional mind the parallel progress I
have been making in personal growth in
enlightenment my partner was asleep at
the time on a futon on the floor she
hadn't returned my calls
wouldn't commit to some office holiday
function I had felt professionally
obligated to attend
she had ignored me so I towered some six
feet above her in a darkened room and
roared berating her accusing her
intimidating her all I lacked was the
belt that my father had used frequently
on me I talked about the differences
between David brain and and me the most
important of which from my perspective
is that I got help and he didn't the
woman I just described was a clinical
psychologist and she insisted that if we
were to become wife and husband I would
in fact undergo therapy and I didn't
need work I didn't need therapy I was a
pretty happy person yes occasionally I
shouted and occasionally I said things I
regretted but for God's sakes that
wasn't domestic violence it wasn't even
really emotional abuse that was just you
know anger while I never entertained the
thought of physically attacking my
partner I knew it was in there
percolating the potential for physically
wounding violence therapy was a great
gift it helped me understand and deal
with the sources of my childhood wounds
and my adult insecurities it informed me
that my parents discipline especially my
father's was as unlawful as it was
ineffective it reinforced my fundamental
belief in the moral and liberating value
of true gender equality and it erased
any excuse I may have had for my
behavior I was responsible
not mommy not daddy not God not Twinkies
and certainly not my partner
excuse me
since I'm in a confessional mood this
evening chapter two seems to be in order
I floated into the conference room and
settled into a chair that seemed to have
been constructed of warm air and goose
down
a moment later my colleagues filtered in
in slow motion the contours of their
bodies blurring into gold and cerulean
eras these were the finest individuals
in the universe worthy noble virtuous it
was a marvelous meeting each person
respectful no one interrupting everyone
agreeing with my point of view on every
item on the agenda it was a perfect
Percodan day alcohol had always been my
drug of choice but in the mid 80s I went
to work with my pockets full of
painkillers I popped them throughout the
day long after the misery of a failed
kidney stone extraction had worn off
administrative problems vanished or lost
their weight organizational enemies
became pals dreaded bureaucratic
meetings turned into Pleasant almost
cosmic out-of-body experiences and I
wasn't the only doper in government
there were far more consequential
personages into the drug scene Richard
Nixon depressed over the public's
reaction to Vietnam and Watergate scored
a dealer volume supply of dilantin and
wolf down hundreds if not thousands of
the mood-altering caps from 1970 through
the end of his presidency in 1974 Bill
Clinton denied inhaling but confessed to
puffing Al Gore copped to being a heavy
weed smoker in college George W Bush
refuses to refute accounts he was a coke
stirrer in school and Marion Barry
please
where does it end it doesn't and it's
not just politicians of course or the
occasional police official it's
everybody at least every demographic is
well represented including shock talk
radio hosts like Rush Limbaugh whose
housekeeper kept him supplied with cigar
boxes full of oxycontin and other
narcotics we do like our drugs and so
what if I want to ingest inject sniffs
snort and Heil
a mood or mind-altering substance
whether to find God flee problems or
just feel good that is my business and
that is how I feel that is how I have
felt for many many years I don't believe
I have that right if I'm piloting a
plane serving as a as the engineer on a
train or given that I live on Orcas
Island piloting ferry boats within the
San Juans there are a number of other
occupations where I believe it is
absolutely essential that we satisfy
ourselves as a society and that those
who drive fly or otherwise move mass
transit around this country are not
doing so impaired by their drug use
having said that I'm absolutely
convinced based on 34 years in police
work and since the early 90s when I did
some of my original drug use drug policy
research convinced that this nation's
war on drugs is the most abysmal
obscenely expensive immoral domestic
policy in the history of this country
save slavery we are spending billions
upon billions upon billions of dollars
to enforce laws that are fun
mentally aimed from my point of view at
punishing people that we have elected to
demonize people who use drugs as a civil
right people who abuse drugs and who
have medical problems and who need help
but unless and until we can develop the
courage within all strata of our society
and particularly within certain fields
like law enforcement to say enough that
this is an extravagant waste of time and
money and people it is not just national
in scope it's clearly international as
our drug policies punish indigenous
peoples throughout the world and and and
subsistence farmers in Latin America and
the Middle East I made a big mistake in
this chapter I called emphatically and
with great confidence for
decriminalization of drug use and
medical assistance and a public health
policy for those who need it when in
fact what I really meant to say was
regulated legalization Jack Cole from
leap he's wearing a t-shirt that says
asked me Ana talked to me can explain in
much better detail the distinction
between decriminalization and
legalization legalization was the
position I supported decriminalization
'he's the wrong term that i attached to
it the drug policy reform movement is
not completely innocent as i did my
research i found references to
decriminalization and legalization used
synonymously but it is clearly time for
us to accept the reality that this drug
this nation's drug policy and its war on
drugs
is an abysmal failure and to shift the
money's now being spent on interdiction
on the supply side on enforcement to the
other side of the equation to the demand
side by first allowing that demand to be
satisfied by any adult who chooses to
use any drug any drug and who in
exchange for that choice makes a social
contract to behave responsibly under its
influence you're driving down the street
impaired you're busted you abuse your
spouse a child you're busted you rob a
bank you steal a car you're busted and
don't even think about blaming it on
being under the influence of any drug
including the most pernicious one in our
society which is alcohol don't for God's
sakes think that it's okay to furnish it
to children because it's not see more
and more people are beginning to
recognize that we've got all the laws we
need to deal with the harmful effects of
any form of drug abuse which impinges
upon the rights of others
we call them we call them criminal
statutes so it's time it's well past
time and I'm personally convinced that
the the most fruitful territory that we
need to be plowing right now is law
enforcement I am not the only police
officer I am not the only police chief
former or present who believes in what
I've just shared with you I was in
Kansas City two weeks ago a major cities
chief came up to me and said after
having been given a free copy of the
book the night before and for a
conference that we were all attending
started your book last night I said oh
how far did you get is that I'm about
midway through chapter 3 which meant of
course that he had read the drug drug
chapter and I said well let me have it I
can't disagree with a thing makes
perfect sense it's logical
why don't we try to be effective in this
process of dealing with this nation's
drug problem I said that's music to my
ears can I quote you no are you crazy
absolutely not that he said it to me as
a step and and and I believe as a
relatively new chief as one of them
America's major cities police chiefs and
he will in fact come around to add to
his wisdom the kind of very special
courage it takes to speak out on this
issue with within our institutions
generally and in law enforcement
particularly last excerpt I had to talk
about David brain because I'm in Tacoma
I have to talk about the World Trade
Organization because I hail from Seattle
and it's not that I want to I was out of
the loop on the decision to invite the
WTO Ministerial Conference to Seattle
November the 29th through December the
4th 1999 I'm not sure how I would have
voted anyway for all I knew WTO were the
call letters of a Cleveland radio
station I will say this though having
your ass kicked so completely by
protesters politicians the media your
own cops colleagues from other agencies
and even a former friend does give cause
for pause and reflection so I have done
a lot of reflection on the battle in
Seattle I make in this chapter another
statement that makes me hunger for a
second edition so that I can correct an
impression that I made in the drug
chapter and so that I can add to my own
understanding and share my own
understanding with others about what
happened in that fateful week during the
battle in Seattle on Tuesday of that
week having worked our way through a
weekend and a Monday with relatively few
problems a handful of
arrests most of them applauded by most
people in our community and having been
approached by a woman who said to me in
the presence of David Horsley the
two-time Pulitzer Prize winning
cartoonist for the P I I love you folks
I love my Police Department that's why
I'm here oh by the way I'm
anti-globalization so I'm also here to
protest this conference but to do so
peacefully and non violently so having
heard that and having expected on the
following day to see a warm and fuzzy
cartoon in the p i-- i was really taken
aback to put it mildly to see how large
how forceful and how violent were small
contingents within that larger mass of
anti-globalization demonstrators in the
city of seattle I went home and did a
lot of studying when I learned that the
WTO was coming to our city having bested
San Diego in competition for the honor
my friends in San Diego never will let
me live that one down but I was I was
convinced that that this was a dialogue
well worth having my own personal view
speaking as a private citizen is that
globalization has wrought horrific
problems globally they are worsening by
the moment and they continue to portend
horrible abuses human rights civil
rights economic and social justice
around the world
that's one person's opinion it's
obviously shared by many many around the
globe but I was in fact Seattle's police
chief in 1999 and my responsibility was
to help all of us achieve safe streets
so that the dialogue so that the
demonstrations in the protests could
proceed a pace throughout that week I'll
conclude by telling you that while I
accept full responsibility
for what happened certainly for the
police response to what happened Andrew
to this day many of the decisions that I
made including one that I didn't make
which would have been to walk across the
street and tell the mayor and every
other politician in town that this city
is too small for this conference upwards
of 50,000 demonstrators 8,000 ministers
international press the President of the
United States the Secretary of State
assorted other very high ranking
officials we didn't have enough people
in the state of Washington much less the
County of King or the City of Seattle
and I should have recognized that early
on and didn't and and I'm and I'm very
regretful that I didn't but I will also
tell you that we made a big mistake on
Tuesday morning of that week in gassing
several hundred if not a thousand
demonstrators who had locked arms and
set themselves in the intersection of
sixth and Union we gassed them because
we didn't have enough people that was
our rationale we gassed them because the
intersection was completely clogged and
somebody on the 27th floor the Sheraton
might have been having a heart attack
and you couldn't possibly get aid cars
through there I believe this i reaiiy
believed it as a cop give us at least a
corridor we would say to the
demonstrators some space through which
we could in fact get an emergency
vehicle will cut all other vehicle ER
traffic they weren't willing to do that
they wanted for reasons that we all I
think understand the photo op civil
disobedience an opportunity to be
arrested by the police in a highly
visible way and to be carted off to jail
we couldn't we couldn't live up to our
own promise to provide that because at
the same time simultaneously were five
other demonstrations or contingents of
demonstrators converging on the downtown
area so a decision was made for those
reasons to clear that intersection
unlawful assembly was declared warning
was administered repeatedly over and
over and over and then they were gassed
and that had the effect the inevitable
effect of radicalizing and making more
militant many many demonstrators who
were on the streets of our city to
protest globalization I write in this
book with great confidence if not
cockiness that if I had that decision to
make over again I'd do it today and I
wouldn't so I really need that second
edition I need the opportunity to say
that on my book tour having heard from
yet more demonstrators and having had
the opportunity to reflect for five
years on that fateful decision that it
really was the wrong choice and it seems
to me that we all need to learn
everything we possibly can not only
about massive demonstrations protesting
whatever but also every other policy and
practice of our Police Department in the
end we are the people's police the
police in this country belong to the
communities they serve
and the day of unilateral
decision-making needs to come to an end
yesterday authentic partnerships between
community and police to advise and to
participate in the development of
policies and procedures program
development crisis management and most
critically civilian oversight of our
police agencies then we when we reach
that level of true authentic partnership
between community and police we can
create solutions to the kinds of
problems that get symbolized in these
huge blow ups or Ana Rodney King
incident an amadou diallo or an Abner
Louima incident police and community
working seamlessly in true partnership
not only to fight crime and solve
problems but to ensure social justice
for each and every one of
that's the end of my talk and I'm now
prepared to take questions comments
reflections that you may have thank you
yes so I'll try my best to sum all the
topics you brought up into one word I
mean whether it's the origins and
domestic violence or the rise of
paramilitarism in the police force or
even WTO its control but the tide is
going really strongly not in the favor
of decentralization of D control but
more control pick your topic you know
the real I you know from the Real ID
movement to to No Child Left Behind to I
mean everywhere you go it's more
centralized top-down take it you know
take it and like it control from every
organ of big business big government
whatever you pick so my question to you
is you know where where do you push back
where are you where are you trying to
you know what would you recommend to try
and undo the way the tide is running
community organization and mobilization
is my immediate response to that I was
giving a reading at Powell's in Portland
a couple of weeks back and a fellow was
sitting in the front row wearing a
Kucinich t-shirt under his shirt raised
his hand when we got to this portion of
the presentation and he said you know
this stuff sounds really good
demilitarized the police legalize drugs
get the government off our backs in in
in ways where we the people want them
off our backs and bring them in to
provide more support in domestic
violence prevention and youth violence
and so on and so forth school violence
so he said you know it all sounds
wonderful it really does but come on
let's be realistic what can we really do
and I said that coming from a man and a
percentage t-shirt come on
why did why were you behind that
candidate because you believed in him on
the issues that you raised and he was
not in his head and I and I said it
really is a political proposition
fundamentally the power of Americans who
feel and believe who as we do and I make
that assumption
with some confidence but not complete
that we want the police to be
accountable we want them to be
responsive and responsible we want them
to be tough crime fighters crime scares
the bejesus out of us predatory street
crimes rapes somebody still in your car
that's no fun we want good police
protection and service and effective
crime-fighting and we also want these
other things that you shared that's not
going to come about and through the work
of any one individual or even small
collection of individuals it is going to
take a large number of Americans
speaking out and clearly you know
hauling their bodies into the polling
booths at election time I've never been
more concerned about the direction of
this country the Homeland Security the
rubric of homeland security is now being
used as an excuse to pull away from
community policing to shift money out of
crime prevention domestic violence
prevention and the like and to what end
there's probably no one in this room
that doesn't believe there's going to be
another terrorist attack in this country
but the last one was in 2001 and day in
and day out on the streets of this city
and every other city in this country
police officers are making awesomely
important discretionary decisions what
are we doing to help them and the
community work together to deal with
being the kinds of real crime problems
that we face in the country other than
that I have no opinion I yeah III think
it's just vital that we organize and
mobilize tipping point tells us it
doesn't have to be 51% it might be 8
percent it might be 7 - who knows but
it's real important I think
that we band together and support one
another and put aside turf battles in
the interests of coalition politics
effective coalition politics so what
organizations do you belong to
well I just joined Law Enforcement
Against Prohibition I am on the board of
the San Juan County domestic violence
and sexual assault services I continue
to be a member of an organization called
liske which is the local initiative
strategic corporation they provide
funding for community development
particularly in low-income areas they're
doing stuff on prisoner re-entry they're
doing some really wonderful things and
I'm proud to be a part of that and an
organization that I recommend to
everyone in this room which is a
fledgling Institute is the Institute for
the for developing police leaders my
friend and colleague Nancy McPherson now
in Portland is is the founder Robin
bowler is a senior fellow yeah never
understood why it's fellow but the two
of us are senior fellows on this in and
hoping to get financing for it it's a
wonderful program that aims to cultivate
progressive police leadership not at the
top because in effect it's too late but
at the lower levels at the rank-and-file
levels these strong peer leaders have
got good sensibilities and a strong
moral and ethical compass we want to
reach out to them and provide tremendous
support over the course of ten full
years apart from a threshold training
and education experience that will help
them do the kinds of things we're
talking about from within yes please you
said something at the very beginning
that I'm not sure I understood correctly
but I thought I heard you say that as a
young police officer or police officers
abuse citizens really confused me
because I've never ever had that
experience knock on wood thank God but
part of that I think could probably be
because I'm not doing the things that
might want to make a police officer
abuse me - and I don't know what part of
that equation fits into that statement
well if you had crossed paths with me or
I with you during my rookie year in San
Diego and you were male and particularly
if you were of color and especially if
you gave me any lip I would try to find
a way to bait you into taking a swing at
me so that I could choke you out right
but if I'm not if I'm just walking down
the street and I'm a good person and I'm
not doing anything wrong you wouldn't
say oh there's a black man let me pick
on him would you
yes oh okay and I wasn't alone
but not just any black man it's got to
be a young black man it's got to be
somebody who is signaling to me that
he's questioning my power my authority
and then I'm gonna find a way an excuse
to stop him and as I said I'm going to
taunt him or bait him into taking a
swing at me I got my comeuppance at the
hands of a prosecutor and people who
know my personal story are well aware of
this incident i arrested a 19 as a kid
happened to be white but I arrested a 19
year old for no other reason than he had
challenged my authority he had some beer
on his breath
that gave me license as I saw it to
arrest him it was a false arrest it was
illegal what I did but I hooked him up
put him in a back seat of my police car
and drove him to jail I didn't screen
test him which is a tactic familiar to
many in early police circles
which is to say and this is how it would
manifest on the police arrest report
while driving the defendant southbound
on Fairmont approaching home Avenue an
orange and white striped cat darted in
front of the undersigned police vehicle
causing the undersigned to slam on the
brakes and forcing the defendant forward
into the screen producing a waffle like
effect on his face inexcusable and a
such a source of of Glee and pleasure
when it was done physical violence abuse
I get it now I understand why that power
went to my head I didn't understand it
at the time that I walked into the
courthouse to respond to this subpoena
that I got on this 19 year old you don't
go did he don't go to court on a
straight drunk arrest in 1966-67 you pay
your twenty nine dollars and get on with
your life we sort of expected people to
do that no problem I thought I've seen
how this is handled so I saunter into
the courthouse i sidle up to the deputy
prosecutor give him a wink and a poke
and say I think you probably want to
dismiss this case he says why I say it's
skinny he says tell me about it
I said well he really had a very bad
attitude I'm cleaning this up he really
had a very bad attitude
so was he drunk so what kind of question
is that he had a really big all me a pig
and I figured you know the wink and the
Pope that's all we we got it going
between the two of us I'd seen senior
officers accomplish this was he drunk no
officer Stamper does the Constitution of
the United States mean anything to you I
was enraged what right did he have to
talk to me that way - what right that he
had to challenge my authority
my rage very quickly turned to
embarrassment and by the time I
slithered down the stairs of the County
Courthouse
I was litter
a wash in shame and that was that was a
defining moment in my life there were
other factors starting to converge but
but I was forced to confront why and how
I had changed so much in such a short
period of time just by pinning on a
badge and putting on a uniform and
packing a gun and behaving in in in ways
that were for me pleasurable but utterly
disgusting I also did some good police
work during my rookie year and I'm proud
of that
but I think what's important to focus on
is you know if we're all about reform
and improvement is what's going wrong
and that was clearly something that was
going wrong
Thanks yes Robin you acknowledge that
you would see a young black man and if
he if he didn't kind of defer to you in
in doing that of course you're
definitely breaking a deep silence and
white solidarity and police codes and
all kinds of things and so on the one I
kind of two-part question I'm interested
in how current officers are responding
to you breaking silence on that and then
whether it's getting do I imagine that
it would get dismissed as okay maybe
some people did that back then but that
doesn't happen now and I'm so I'm also
wonder what your perspective is on race
relations with police and community of
color today that's changed and just I'll
start with the last one work back it has
changed there has been improvement and
it's visible obvious improvement you'd
have to be awfully stupid to use the
kind of racial and ethnic slurs that I
described in this book that we're taking
place in the everyday vocabulary of
police officers in the mid 70s you'd
have to be awfully stupid because in
that police department in San Diego in
the one in Seattle and I'm assuming in
Tacoma that will get you fired and you
cannot believe the debates we had about
that what it's just words as a you know
think of the grossest most primitive and
ugly and grotesque racial and ethnic
slurs you can imagine those were in
common use in the early stages of Mike
career and when it came time to finally
confront that with police chief saying
these walls have heard for the last time
the inward use that word the expression
of our chief in San Diego was convair
hiring because you're out of a job well
that's great that's wonderful
non-negotiable standards of performance
and conduct you want to be a cop in this
city you got to do these things and not
do these things otherwise you won't be
that's terrific but it's far from enough
and as you to well know having taught
cultural competence for many many years
and offshoots of that discipline what's
really needed now especially in those
departments that have made that progress
is cultivating an environment in which
we can have honest conversation about
race and we are not they're not in any
Police Department I know I have a
chapter entitled white white cops kill
black men it's intentionally provocative
but it raises very important questions
that deserve to provoke honest
conversation about white police officers
fears of black men why do you think I
did what I did when I'd see a 17 18 or a
25 year old black male walking down the
street give me the eye because I was
scared well if you're scared wouldn't
you drive on by no I'm a cop
I'm not going to just drive on by
so I think just to complete this answer
I think great progress has been made
I think the status of race relations in
the society as well as within our
institutions including particularly
policing is still dismal I really do
believe that and I probably missed
another part of that question Robin so
you can I'm just wondering what kind of
reaction oh it's really mixed I've had
some amazingly positive reactions I've
read the reviews on Amazon I don't know
if anybody can resist that and there's a
campaign to get me it's real clear not
not to get me it's driving my sales down
I'm sure give me those one-star reviews
and I know the book I know who's writing
them you know it's and it's actually
kind of humorous particularly since my
publisher keeps telling me you want
controversy listen no I don't listen I
you know this person's wrong I think I
need to reap no you don't no no let it
go that's good
but there's positive stuff here is there
what a flip side to that like black
officers killing white men no are the
same reason no because it's not there
there's no pattern is there why are
white officers afraid of black men and
black officers not afraid of white men I
think it has to do with privileged
status entitlement it has to do with my
taking for granted my whiteness if you
are of color you are the ethnic minority
if you grow up in a police department
you are taught I don't want to be unduly
provocative I was taught to recognize
that black men if I was going to get
done as a cop is going to be at the
hands of a black men and pull a knife
and stuck it between my ribs or a thirty
two out of his waistband and shot me
between the eyes I believe that I
honestly believe that because that is
really what I was taught not in a class
entitled how black men are out to kill
Hawaii cops right it was in the stories
that all the instructors told you know
the sea stories the accounts of what
happened at 30th and Imperial there five
thousand church were forty seven hundred
Logan and the cast was always white cop
on black man do do black officers have
that same fear of black youth also then
I would say as a generalization no as a
generalization no
one of the officers I interviewed 31
officers in 1976 asking each of them
about their own practices and what they
witness in policing the black community
this was in response to an investigation
that we initiated which i think is
another very positive sign in that
Police Department in San Diego one of my
31 cops was black
this is officers assigned to the black
community because you're pre good idea
of how few black officers there what
there were in it in that Police
Department that time when I began to ask
this officer in this black officer
whether essentially he engaged in the
same stuff that thirty other cops have
basically copped out to he said yes I
had a series of questions that got into
details and specifics and he began
weeping it's not an unfair
characterization to say that he was
sobbing uncontrollably he was ashamed
thoroughly ashamed of using racial and
ethnic slurs you know the answer
probably you got to ask the question why
did you do this you go along to get
along
it's a white world it's a white locker
room the cops have cover you out there
on the street to back you up they're
white tragic just tragic
yes one more question we want to have
time for autographs in great thanks I
hate the pressure of asking the last
better it really better be good it's
really good I'm just curious as a result
of this discussion this is asking you to
generalize but you've been comfortable
doing that with some other things
earlier do you think the majority of
people go into police work for
altruistic reasons or because they like
the idea of I will be this really
powerful fabulous guy that can rough up
those people that I want to rough up
some show psychological traits that
support that latter premise that they
are authoritarian they're very control
oriented they have something to prove
something to establish which was clearly
my case the badge becomes very heavy for
those officers the best solution to that
of course is to keep the badge from them
in the first place
psychological screening has taken great
strides over the decades so that we're
actually pretty good at screening out
the blatantly unfit we're not as good
yet i DPL is to for developing police
leaders as a psychologist on board who
is very very good at helping us to get
to a state of art where we can actually
find those qualities that would be
useful for police officers not just the
absence of bad so to speak but the
presence of good qualities most police
officers today whether they have an
altruistic motive or not are honest and
honorable people they're good people my
beef is not with cops I love them dearly
even some of the ones I've had to fire I
have tremendous respect and admiration
for however twisted that may sound they
tried they just didn't succeed but there
is I think a real problem in assuming
that we can let the culture as it exists
today absorbed newcomers and not turnout
officers who are cynical or sarcastic or
who never smile or who are given to
excessive force or who won't explain
their actions or who worse engage in
racist or discriminatory or excessive
conduct so it's real important I think
to look at the structure which gives
rise to that culture which produces the
events it ain't the people it's you and
me it's our society we draw our comes
from society at large it's the structure
thank you all very much thank you thank
you all so much for coming
norm Stamper served as the Andals chief
of police from 1994 until his retirement
in 2000 pricking rank is published by
thunders mouth press visit Avalon pub
comm for more information